[Music]
so hello everybody welcome to chess in
the Romantic era for those in YouTube my
name is Pepe cuenca - spanish colonial
in resident here in the st. louis chess
club happy to be here with all of you
today I'm gonna talk about above under
scim you guys know who was a loaf
anderson no okay it's one of my favorite
chess players he was considered to be
the best chess player in the world in
the 19th century actually he was some
mathematicians he started mathematics
and also philosophy and his main job was
high school teacher but then as a hobby
he was the best chess player in the
world yes sir but yes the one who
defeated him was Paul Murphy it was a
great American chess player in a tour he
he gave in Europe yeah but probably you
have heard about about understand in
many ways and probably you have seen
many of his games one of his most famous
game is the so called the evergreen game
who was already explained in the st.
Louis chess club channel so I didn't
want to repeat that so I'm gonna show
you two other games which are also very
spectacular so the first one happened
between him with the white pieces and
Leonel albert key is a rich key hard
name to pronounce right normally in
these times they used to play in the
fest for example there were no chess
tournaments organizing the st. Louis
chess club that time and they used to
meet in cafes for example la sessions or
la versions in Paris was a great place
to play chess and best player in the
world
they used to meet over there and okay
this game it was baptised as the
immortal game from out of Anderson like
few years later by another players
and these players in the Romantic era
they were extremely aggressive chests
speaking of course and they really
wanted to attack the opposite king open
files sacrifice everything and yeah they
don't think much about position I'll
play your prophylaxis or stuff like that
yeah all right so I'm going to show you
this first game which is very very
interesting so understand with the white
pcs efore ePHI and of course can't
commit yeah so very aggressive play
what's the King's gambit idea Adie
why are you sacrificing a pond to get
something in return you get nothing
exactly so you sacrifice this F pawn in
order to gain some control in the center
right so lately you're gonna play d4 and
Knight f3 for example and you are
gaining a lot of control in the center
and hopefully you will get this pawn
back in the future right the f4 point
here there are two main variations so
you can play Knight f3 or you can play
Bishop c4 Bishop c4 was played with 93
just top Queen h4 check with Bishop c4
you stop d5 which is one of the most
common Black's ideas in this position so
Bishop if d4 sorry c4 was played the
main drawback is that black can play
Queen h4 check right and this was played
in the game it's nothing serious as
white can play keen f1 later you're
gonna play Knight f3 and win another
tempo kicking the screen from 8/4 and
here a very interesting move maybe not a
move that we would see today b5 another
pawn sacrifice by Kia's wretzky here's a
risky Black's idea is maybe very simple
so this Bishop was on c4 perfectly
placed pointing to the f7 point which is
the weakest point the black house in
this position
and also now after some of like c6 you
will gain another tempo and you are
ready to strike in the center with d5
also this Bishop can come to b7 put in
some pressure on the e4 pawn Knight f6
was played by Kia each key attacking the
e4 pawn and now a natural move
developing appears and protecting or
attacking black screen Knight f3 Knight
f3 so here two different approaches you
could go Queen age 5 or Queen 8 6 to me
Queen 8 6 looks more natural since you
are protecting f4 and maybe you are
ready to go g5 at some point right d3
was played now you protect the e4 pawn
and you put an eye on the f4 pawn again
and here what will you play here with
the black pieces
not h5 exactly this is what Kea said
it's Keyblade it's a really natural move
so you protect f4 and then you are
threatening something exactly
so I black if white ghost Knight c3 then
93 just wins because of the H takes the
rookin h1 is just hanging
so after 9 H 5 above understand stop
this thread by playing Knight rage for
now let's for now stops not g3 because
now it doesn't make any sense
we can just capture the night and now we
are aiming to go to the f5 squared
alright so black played Queen to g5
attacking this night on h4 and now
attacking also the bishop on from b5 so
what's the only move not to blunder
peace resign somebody's saying sorry yes
Knight a5 right so now to peer the two
pieces are protected
okay so c6 was played here you could say
that g6 is interesting right because now
if I just move my knight back then this
Bishop is gonna be hanging but there is
8 for Queen f6 and now Knight c3 very
interesting move since now you can take
on f5 but the night on h5 is hanging so
and also you are threatening to go to d5
with this night let's say G takes f 5
sorry G takes a5 Queen takes h5 and this
is a very messy position so after 95
instead of g6 Piazza leads key played c6
attacking this Bishop and now of course
it was possible to go Bishop c4 but
after Bishop c4 but will you play here
with the black thisis active move
candidate moves what do you play Bishop
Bishop e6 all right
that's reasonable but there is a better
mo here
d5 exactly now to attack this Bishop
it's not possible to capture here
because the knight on f5 is hanging
right and then when this bishop goes
back you just capture an f5 then blacks
upon app so after c6 instead these guys
were brilliant and understand didn't go
for Bishop c4 instead he played the move
g4 crazy right attacking this Knight
from age 5 and now of course you cannot
take on person because the Queen is
hanging so you can now take this Bishop
or move the knight right you take this
Bishop she takes h5 let's say d5 rook
Jiwon Queen f6 and Knight c3 white
pieces are extremely well coordinated
this Knight is jumping to d5 this Bishop
is coming to effort the Rajasthan G file
so basically white is much better here
let's say D takes e4 d takes e4 and now
this night is coming to d5 with a lot of
pressure so that's why after g4 this
night was retreated to f6 and now again
I was analyzing this game and I was
hoping some Bishop c4 some [ __ ] away
before right as a natural human being
but understand he played Droog g1 here
let's just try to understand this move
again after sorry again as their Bishop
after Bishop c4 same move first h5g
takes and now d5 right so ruiji one was
played
and the thing is that now after seat XV
five of us happen in the game you're
gonna play h4 and this Queen hasn't got
too many squares so she takes me five
eight four queen g6 only move and now
what do you play here with the white
pieces if you had two moves you will
play a Bishop f4 and h5 and there is no
square for the Queen sorry
so basically there are two options right
to reason reasonable options you can
play Bishop f4 or you can play h5 but
this is a big difference you play Bishop
f4 okay how about you guys Bishop f4 or
h5 85 okay
the problem with Bishop f4 is that now
black can play eight five and the queen
is more or less safe and blacks apisa
after g5 g just moved the night away and
nothing bad happens so the best move is
eight five and after Queen g5 only move
wing to f3 now it's very tough for black
to protect this f4 point basically your
threat is Bishop f4 just winning again
on the spot
so you have to run away with your queen
and it's not easy how you run away with
your queen sorry
I think moved your knight exactly this
is precisely what kia said it's he did
and he went Knight eg8 because there are
not so many squares available right and
now
to just take an F for Queen f6 and
another developing move Knight to c3
look at these positions so okay black is
a piece up but look at the coordination
of white pieces every piece is out all
black pieces are in the back trunk
this Knight is joining the party by a d5
and if I was also possible g5 is also
possible so basically it's a very tough
position for black Bishop c5 was played
trying to develop another piece
attacking the rook on g1 and now we
would think like okay now understand
sacrifice in off pieces so he will go
root G 2 and then 95 or Santi but no he
went straight away for 95 another good
move and here he s edit key to come B to
basically not basically now black is
threatening the rook on a1 and the rook
on g1 I'm here according to the engines
that we have today understand made a
mistake he played the move Bishop d6
we're gonna start we're gonna try to
understand that move later but the best
move here was rook e1 not an easy move
though right because after Bishop g1
there is Knight d6 check King d89 f7
Keaney 8 only move Knight d6 kin d8 + e5
and it's just impossible to stop Bishop
g5 check and white is winning but Bishop
d6 was played here idea is pretty simple
so after Bishop d6 you want to go 936
and then f7 pawn is hanging but the
first question that comes to our mind is
is possible to take broken a1 or drew
code g1 what
white threat here so we want to take the
Bishop on c5 so kissing each kid took
the rukon g1 it was very interesting to
see what happens after Queen takes a one
king II - and do you think that black
can take on g1 or not Bishop d6 was a
really beautiful move because it's
sacrificing both rooks and now black
can't take the rook on g1 y checkmate in
two moves exactly ninety seven only move
kin d8 and Bishop c7 all right
so kissing is key played Bishop g1 and
we're gonna see what happened later the
best move for black here was Queen a1
king e 2 and Queen B - the most
important thing is to keep an eye on
this g7 point so if you take on g1 then
97 followed by Bishop c7 c8 checkmate
but after Queen B - the position is not
very clear so the engines are suggesting
Bishop takes e5 Queen c2 in f1 Queen c5
and Queen f4 and the engines say that
this position is around equal it's crazy
right because we're a rock and a piece
down but we have a lot of activity here
we are threatening 96 97 96 followed by
nerve cell native 7 sorry or Queen f7
this is just crazy you can play with the
ng and a little bit and try to
understand what's going on but ok he
took on g1 and now brilliant move e5
cutting the action of the Queen over the
g7 square
and basically there's no way of stopping
Knight g7 right so what's white threat
here do you want to take on g7 and you
want to play Bishop c7 so first he took
on a one that looks rigors reasonable
it's a check and I get a rook for free
I love for for free right so Queen a one
kidney - and now how do you stop the
maintenance e7 let's see if you guys
think like psh key 986 great it looks
like black is winning right 96 and then
after 1917 d8 then there's no bishops e7
checkmate
so black is a queen and two rooks
up but there is a extremely beautiful
finish and that's why this game is
called the immortal game after 96 let's
see if you guys can find the mate about
the people in YouTube you guys can see
something there's checkmate here
checkmate in three moves
yeah I'm then after kin da
the Queen can deflect the night
beautiful that's the solution so 90 xe7
King d8 and now Queen f6 and after not
f6 Bishop e7 checkmate only with three
minor pieces in the board black is rook
two rooks and a queen and a piece ah
yeah so he sacrificed everything even I
think he sacrificed even his glasses or
something yet yes exactly
after E 5 Queen a wonky knee - now
there's no way of stopping 97 and Bishop
c7 let's say for example that you want
to play something like Bishop e7 right
so in order to have the c8 squared so
how do we finish our opponent here
next thing altogether let's say 97 King
d8 for example I guess Queen f7 works
right what do you play here with black
this Queen e8 mate
there is 96 common for example you play
nitrate 6 it's not that easy right let's
go back let's think all together so
Bishop e7 here how do we finish our
opponent
can you spot it
so let's say 97 kindy 8 I think this
wins yeah here here there here here
check beautiful rook takes and 97
exactly yeah before Bishop d7 yeah
97 kin d8 okay but are you threatening
something now because I think I have
some time now - maybe it's also waning
yeah but let's let's say I do something
like Queen C 1 yeah so what I want to do
is to capture and C 2 and then to give
you a thousand of text maybe you can
take on a eight and still winning I
don't know but I think the other
variation is more forced right okay so
this is the immortal game I want to show
you another game from understand where
he played the Evans gambit another
interesting opening with the white
pieces that we don't see that often
today in the top tournaments and let's
go let's go yeah this game is between
understand and sukitooru johannes su
couture in in germany in 1869
so if 45 93 96 Bishop c4 how this is
called the Spanish tree Lopez Italian
right
Spanish relabel is after Bishop b5 right
so Bishop c4 Italian and now Bishop c5
is the main move here in this position
and the Aran
Evans gambit goes after before avi
what's the idea of before yeah exactly
so the same idea as before as the King
gambit so you sacrifice some not asking
that important point and in return you
get the center right so here as Adi says
what place c3 in order to install this
beautiful Center on d4 here there are
several options I want to recommend you
one alternative for black here the
variation that I play
so here the main line is Bishop a5 but
each of East 7 is very interesting the
idea is of the d4 you want to go near a
5 and it looks like we are given the
pawn back after 95 that's true but you
win the bishop / 94 night c4 and d5 then
you open this iron for this Bishop and
this position is very very healthy for
black of course after Bishop e7 95 white
can't retreat this pawn and again the
idea is to give this ePHI phone back you
don't want to take on d4 is too much
center for black for white sorry
instead you play d6 and let's say
something like queenie for c6 and this
position it's it's also great for for
black I mean it's a matter of taste you
can also play Bishop a5 as they did in
this game which is perfectly natural
so the bishop on e5 does a fantastic job
because now if the d 4e txt for you can
never take back with the pawns in stairs
up in saudi for any way it was played
it's active for and shortcuts understand
sacrificing three points for example you
take on c3 then Queen b3 that's
precisely White's idea like to attack
this pawn on f7 and let's say after
Queen a seven-night c3 threatening to go
to d5 and then you have to capture on c3
these two bishops are like two monsters
yeah there are extremely dangerous
these bishops on c4 and b2 and later on
you will open files with a five so
that's why this is too dangerous and
black plays a prophylactic move Bishop
b6 maybe looks a little bit stupid
what's the bishop doing there but the
thing is it's a prophylactic move
against Queen b3 White Queen b3 is not a
very good move now exactly notified
perfect the point is after Bishop f17 f8
there is no efficient way of protecting
this bishop on f7 did you play something
like 25 how do you finish c6 alright I
think okay this is risky or maybe
doesn't win because of Queen d6 k n f7
alright you still got Keaney 8 and
nothing happens I think but Knight f6
it's easier right
attack the Queen there are no checks
next move to capture this guy and blacks
better so that's why Bishop basics is so
nice because there's no Queen b3 move so
instead white took on d4 C taxi for and
Disick was played you don't want to go
on air f6 straight away why you don't
want to go native six
while you think black played these six
first unknown out of six straight away -
stop what - stop be five right now if I
was very strong this night has nowhere
to go I mean g4 doesn't look very good
you can just kick this knife back by
playing a three we'll have to go back to
eight six like these smells really bad
right
so that's why this X is played first so
in order to stop if I'm and later you
can develop your night by playing Knight
f6 or even ninety seven so d5 was played
by Anderson maybe this is not the most
natural move because you are closing the
diagonal for this Bishop but the thing
is you're opening another one for maybe
an even stronger Bishop you want to go D
5 and then Bishop b2 and the bishop is a
fantastic piece D if I was played nine a
five Bishop b2 attacking g7 and here you
can't capture the bishop on c4 right
because there is Bishop g7 and then the
next moves you're going to capture the
room from h8 and what is just is just
better right so that's why black played
97 and do you think it's possible to
take on g7 now
yes but more important than that
after Ruchi aid there are two pieces
hanging right so Bishop g7 root g8 and
now there is no way of stopping to
blunder any of this bishops right or one
of those bishops sorry
yeah Bishop III and then you're just a
piece up so you cannot defend both
pieces at the same time so that's why
Bishop g7 is just a blunder so that's
why I'm not understand didn't go for
this and instead he just played the most
natural move Bishop d3 Bishop d3 short
Castle and Knight to c3 okay
Black's upon app but this Bishop is very
very good and there is some compensation
for sure the knight is also not properly
placed on a5 right not so many tasty
squares for this night so that's why
this song compensation in this position
96 was played and Knight to e2 now this
Bishop is targeting the g7 squared there
could be some plans related by bringing
this Knight to g3 and then to f5 or even
to age 5 to 4 add to force f6 and then
this squared would be very very weak
here Sucher fort or Sukkot or plate c5
it's a natural move I would prefer to
place something like c6 here pouring
some pressure on the center and then not
closing this diagonal for this Bishop c5
makes on sense because now you have a
passport and maybe you want to go c4 in
some position but this c6 makes more
sense for me I don't know see if I was
played Queen to d2 connecting the rooks
and now f6 was played maybe it was not
necessary maybe Bishop g4 make a little
bit more sense here I guess he was
afraid of something like Queen c3 f6 and
Knight to g5 given the fact that you
can't take because there's checkmate in
g7 great but what's the best move here
for black black moves and wins again 40
moves always the same thing I know but
it works captures checks and threats can
we check no can we capture something yes
this guy but not a very good idea right
checkmate in one move then Bishop e2
also another possibility so those are
the possible captures what are the
threats can we thread something come
with red some peace with a simple move
95 exactly that's very reasonable
another another one so you are
threatening this night from g5 how do
you thread the bishop from d3 with a
simple move yeah D exactly c4 great c4
deviation deflection not deviation right
deflection now you can't take on c4
because of the Knight takes Queen takes
you will be able to take on g5 and you
can't move the bishop back to C 2
because the night only two is hanging so
that's why c4 is such an strong move
right so Bishop g4 was very interesting
instead Sucher talk I love this name sue
Carter
he played f6 and here understand into h1
alright maybe as you can see in the game
he will try something on the G file
Bishop c7 was played very natural so
maybe you want to expand your majority
you wanna make use of that so you got
three versus one so it's always good to
advance to push those bonds Lucchesi one
so no more c4 moves rook b8 and night to
g3 here by Anderson who wants to join
the party jumped into f5 and putting
some pressure here b5 was played and
Knight to f5 but you guys think it's a
great idea to take on f5 or you just
want to continue your plan on the Queen
side I mean the first move that came to
my mind when I was analyzing this posit
this this gang was Bishop f5 so i'm
material up so I want to exchange on
pieces but then I realized there were
some troubles
what happens after Bishop f5 8x f5 we
would love to go to e5 but is that
really possible
what would you play here with the white
pieces
simple chess captures checks on threats
sorry Knight takes e5 right okay but
what happens if I just take with my pawn
there's nothing direct right but that's
the method yeah you check all the
captures so check the other one yeah and
now if I take with my D pawn what
happens now maybe you can see
unprotected pieces simple exactly
exactly the opponent c5 is hanging so
rook takes e5 and if black takes back
with the F pawn what do you play
exactly that's the key
so if black text with f1 then Mac g5 and
then this night is going to be extremely
strong on e6 there are many many threads
here also you're put keeping an eye on
egg on 87 but then I just arrived into e
six just is just too good for white so
that's why it's not that easy to take on
f5 and soo character played before here
expanding his majority and now
understand as you remember these players
were very very aggressive and he plays
rook to g1 he wants to push the Jeep on
and then try to open this day I went out
for this Bishop also as you are gonna
see in the game after g4 there are so
many words related by bringing the root
2 G 3 and 2 a 3 or even doubling rooks
on the g5 looks very interesting so last
chance to take on f5 it's now never
because if you wait one more more ass it
happened in the game after g4 whenever
Bishop takes on f5 GTX f5 is going to
open this dangerous file for black so
now it's even more dangerous to take on
f5 95 was played at this moment and
[Music]
again we have to analyze all the
captures and Bishop takes e5 was played
same idea if black takes back with a
pond with f6 pawn Knight to g5 and 96
coming but maybe this was the best
option for black because after D takes
e5 now white starts attacking with Group
g3
and it's not easy to push this pawn to
c4 right you will have to bring a queen
to c7 and then it's not easy
ruk f7 was played by sue couture and g5
opening the opening lines yeah
since this game on g8 is not very safe
now
Bishop f5 e takes f5 and now sugar turd
blundered maybe the best move was c4
Bishop takes Knight takes rook takes and
rook c8 exchanging some pieces so the
attack is not so dangerous anymore but
he played point to d5 and what do you
play here with the white pieces
j6 all right let's see what happens so
for example I think I can play rook d7
and now you are the one with troubles on
the D file right
I'm threatening to play E 4 or even c4
looks annoyed for white right I don't
know I'm just analyzing with you guys so
maybe I'm just on 87 yes and now I will
play King h8
so you can't move the f3 night since
there is a pin your queen on g2 is
unprotected so if four is a threat g7 is
protected so it looks to me that
Blackie's could be even better
okay so g6 very interesting more moves
again I'm gonna keep telling you guys
the same thing for these two weeks but
it's just first moves it sounds really
trivial but it works captures check some
threads D takes f6 and after rook takes
f6 exactly you see so capture and then
threat how can I can i threat the Queen
yes Bishop c4 maybe it is a - it's
stupid but many times you find that it's
not Bishop c4 just wins on the spot so
after Knight c420 xe5 check and you
can't move the claim because there is a
ping here so that's why Queen d5 was a
blunder after G takes f6 you can't take
back and if you can't take back you're
going to bring this other rook to the G
file and then something Bad's gonna
happen on g7 alright
so rook d8 was played putting some
pressure on d3 and now root 2 G 1 played
by Anderson so I want to ask you what
happens after Queen takes d3
yeah and suggestions Rock g7 yes
kina fate and now Queen eight-six you
sure
checkmate into four black so Queen eight
six Queen f3 and rook t1 be careful
simple captures
and threats
anybody from the YouTube channel you
guys can see how to finish black here
Knight e5
95 how about if I just take your print
Quinn f1 yeah but I think this also wins
for black so takes takes and takes so
not 95 much more simple than that simple
chest
Brook
rook g8 all right I didn't see that but
okay so if I take wing g5 that's your
idea that's checkmate
so can I go kin f7 here 95 right so
maybe rookie group J twins yeah let me
see
Luke g8 if I take 25 and then Queen g7
and 27 right so can i play King h8 here
yeah that was very good Queen eight six
be careful
Queen a3 and Queen and rook to d1 now
now boom Knight takes e5 same
so you take the Queen rook takes and
Knight takes e5 for example so how you
stop knight of seven this is the this
was a solution that I was gonna propose
you so here just Quin take c3 rook takes
c3 rook g7 he's got to take the west's
checkmate on g8 takes takes King f8 and
holo I threatened checkmate in two moves
Knight g5 in 1396 followed by rookie 7
checkmate
so it's got to resign here - all right
so after rooks C 2 G 1 it's not possible
to take on d3 this is what we just saw
so they played King h8 looks ugly now F
takes G seventh King G 828 six beautiful
the point is that black resigned after
Queen d6 why
Finnish Sucher card the way understand
it in a brilliant style unclean takes
rook h1 soaked in 87 sorry Queen eight
1787 rookie three how about Queen eight
six yes yeah Kintex e7
not that easy right it's more beautiful
so Quinn takes now or after taking on 87
if you do it now I just take on the
three so yeah f6 how about King g8 back
so you wanna go like this
Andrew cage-free I guess I can scape let
me try to find out how
for example rook f6 nope so
okay let's check it out
Knight g5 I think I can't just take here
on g7 or even better go back okay three
and I take on g7 No
perfect Adie awesome that's the solution
keen takes f6 King g8 bishop make seven
brilliant Kim takes root k3 King g8 and
rock h8 on okay so after Queen 817 ah
yes of course f6 Queen text III and same
thing
ruk h3 you can't go to g6 you have to go
back to g8 and rotate six okay
so these two games were the ones that I
wanted to show you in my opinion they're
extremely beautiful
this was the chess in the Romantic era a
lot of sacrifices and attacking chess so
I hope you guys enjoyed the lesson see
you next time
[Music]